I have an idea what you can purge first
Hollywood
can you guess what its logos Comcast
[Music]
interesting terrible it's really not
it's pretty common it's like that
psychologist in t2 who tells a bunch of
colleagues the plot of the first
Terminator and one of them says that's a
result way to pat your own back movie
unemployment rising across the nation
can't think of a clever or compelling
way to give your audience the
information you think they need at the
beginning of your film well now with
News position you don't have to just
throw up some vague split-screen news
clips with some reporter rich sounding
narration and you're good to go News
position for when easy means more to you
than excellence in case you confused it
with Staten Island Gilligan's Island
if you remain on Staten Island during
the experiment you will receive monetary
compensation wouldn't paying the
perjures negate the psychological
motivations for the PERT itself I am I
already feeling like instead of fleshing
out this whole purge concept the origin
story is only gonna make it more obvious
how ridiculous the whole idea was to
begin with this is one of a dozen sites
being set up across the island geez
Willy well I made that news position
cranked earlier I didn't realize you
were gonna go all in on it
we're only six minutes into this thing
and this is the third time you've news
casted me across the face since it
probably won't be the last time that's
just in an extra 35 sins I've just shown
up in your totals will be literally yadi
otters the reason why Stanton King
island was chosen for this experiment
something-something demographics so is
it the most ethnically diverse is it the
most concentrated group of assholes in
the country is there a broader spectrum
of lower to upper class people I don't
doubt that there would be massive
protests for something like this but
this isn't the kind of thing where by
the end of it you look dreamily into the
sky and say this is the time you should
be spending getting the off the island
oh man they dragged poor Marissa Tomei
into this didn't think a lot of people
have a lot of concerns about this and
one concern comes up over and over again
is it free murder cuz it should probably
be all the free murder wait does all
this look so fake
did the filmmakers go out and shoot
b-roll of protesters and then film this
interview in front of a green screen
practicing there is no way that razor
blade was in his mouth through the
entire overacted psychotic psych-out
speech in fact thanks to the wonders of
the pause button I can prove it point is
we got to be prepared for anything
thanks for this pulsating strobing
reaction Chuck that I just first purged
all over the floor let's get through
this purge pull so we could get back to
business as usual this is something
we've had to say it's cinemasins HQ four
times now what are you doing why else
hey six Oh goddamn this movie really
drives home the economic hardships
doesn't it like if you didn't get this
point from the news broadcast at the
beginning or the peak condition to the
apartments they live in what were the
people participating in the purge for
money you have this scene how much dead
can a dead beat beat if a dead beat
could beat dead horses purchase one day
you Demetri destroyed his community 364
days a year
does he skip Christmas because since
there hasn't been a purge it that
technically means he's been destroying
the community for 365 days a year
man I knew in love years ago had courage
that's all I miss them and I miss the
purge movies where I didn't have to sit
through five minutes of relationship
soap opera just to almost get to where
the purging actually starts thanks for
the countdown clock the way this movies
gone I truly hope that's not movie time
also the nice thing about this timer is
it tells me the exact amount of my time
that you're wasting by dedicating the
whole screen to this information instead
of just continuing the movie the answer
by the way is 9 full seconds while the
movie takes great pains to show the
Verrazano Bridge being closed so that
people can't escape Staten Island before
the purge it takes absolutely no pains
to show us what's going on at the Staten
Island Ferry except for a two-second
report about how the last one is leaving
and it is insane that New York City
didn't try to extend ferry service or
add more to the fleet to get people off
the island hell are there some boat
owning citizens who'd like to pull off
their own Dunkirk and help some people
out can it please be the end I'd really
love for it to be the end
god damn it movie aside from the fact
that this is a cheap Halloween
advertisement when did Isaiah get his
hands on a 2018 Halloween poster I
distinctly remember a purge feed showing
me a date of March 21st 2017 in
Jacksonville Florida Halloween was just
a twinkle and dynamic Brides balls back
then this Halloween poster was alive
also remember the first bird you know
not the name of this movie but the
actual first movie thanks for that by
the way every time I refer to the first
bird I'm now going to have to say you
know the first movie not the forth one
that was a prequel that was called the
first perch anyway where was I
murder will be legal for 12 continuous
hours do you really need the including
murder part I mean aren't there other
specifically gruesome crimes that you
might as well mention too you know like
Michael Bay movies also what about
crimes like kidnapping if you take
someone else's kid during the purge is
it just purchase keepers Partizan Oh for
the love of melodrama the thing that
these movies never seem to understand is
that you don't actually need people like
needle ream here to make it scary the
concept is actually scary enough and
strong enough on its own without mucking
it all up with this over-the-top psycho
killer nonsense also I would remove a
thousand sins if this was a secret
he-man movie and it was about Skeletor
purging all of Hemans friends especially
Orca king Orca why are all these bull
contact-lens recorders different colors
is there a reason this guy has green
ones other than the art director decided
it would look cool
also what is up with the super advanced
technology if this is the first purge
why does the technology seem to go
backwards in the future events in the
continuing saga of making the Tecla cool
instead of realistic why would the video
feed from the Contacts look like this
why would the camera pick up any of the
glowing mechanics of the contact is it
somehow shooting from behind them where
is camera also why do they wear two of
them in the first place unless they're
somehow using 3d imaging one contact
would shoot what they are seeing just
fine we believe that this is the first
purge of the evil because despite the
massive scale of this operation one of
us just happened to be watching it also
Birds credits nice try but Skeletor
clearly waited a beat before stabbing
this ATM thief
he didn't go right up to him and stab
him immediately Skeletor believes in
maximum jump scares before he kills
anyone the 23rd psalm says although I
walk through the valley actually it says
through the valley of the shadow of
death not in I'm not saying everyone
would quote it right I'm just saying
this pastor probably what you just told
us right yeah so I know it's the first
personal and there are no rules here but
I'm gonna go ahead and say that these
ladies failed hard at purging I'm glad
they're getting a kick out of the teddy
bear fireworks gauntlet but I give their
efforts to solid F well they finally did
it
Universal combined the fast and furious
with the purge can't wait to see Tyrese
earn his purge paycheck I've gotta ask
why collations 5:16 a passage only
refers to the desires of the flesh which
is the Bible's way of saying don't have
sex it's way way too fun the passage
immediately before this one Galatians
515 makes the most sense but if you bite
and devour one another watch out that
you are not consumed by one another
first kill of the night 20 million views
all right where does it fucking say this
video got 20 million views and according
to the description it got published 9
minutes ago there's no way it got 20
million views already
also why does this app have the video
rotated for landscape when the rest of
the apps functions are in portrait but
I'm gonna go find that psycho how on
earth in the split second that he saw
that video with only a POV shot did he
identify Skeletor even if the movie
isn't saying that it's sequences it that
way
and we reserve the right to sin that
that was with the brief blackout here
for a minute there I thought it was the
failing electricity bailing Dmitriy out
at the last minute but then it's just
the movie blacking out it'll be because
it's had enough addition to all so why
didn't the assassins wait until they
started sexing him to try this and why
not surely if they snuck in knives
they'd have snuck in guns too so far
this has been an even-handed broadcast
but for no reason at all the crawl at
the bottom of the screen says a great
day in America with zero context dark
much movie half of these scenes are
basically just black screens we get it
the glowy contact thingies look cool in
the dark do you mind if we occasionally
see what's going on what are you okay
this is where Isaiah is right now so
what did he tell her I'm in some random
warehouse you know the one Oh fire
perhaps the biggest sin of this whole
purge cool is that none of this feels
remotely interesting we are more than
halfway into this thing and every crime
that's being committed feels like it
could have been in any other crime movie
ever drug lords trying to take each
other out a psycho killer on the loose
we've seen it all before what does any
of this have to do with the
philosophical or hell practical
consequences of this experiment and yes
I know they dip into the government
conspiracy stuff later but all those
conversations take place in about 10
minutes and two scenes the majority is
just some sort of neuter die hard of the
Lambs to society and if anything can be
proven by this first purge experiment
it's that people are ridiculously
patient these people decided to waste
all their time underneath the street
waiting for somebody to walk by for what
must have been hours to pull off this
complex trapdoor spider it's funny
because it's true
Skeletor slices nice throat about
halfway and then we see Isaiah run
towards him giving Skeletor two extra
seconds of throat slicing that will
somehow not kill her as this movie
enters its third hour hmm
you say it's only been 48 minutes well
that suggests that this socio-economic
group is not reacting
that I predicted oh yes let's bring data
and statistics into this overwrought
metaphor for moral decay and should
liven it right up almost got yourself
killed are we gonna talk what here now
why would you talk out here and open
purge season instead of finding
somewhere a little safer to hash out
your trust issues a big town just vote
before and I saw way out skip this guy
wasn't all that serious about the
projects I'm not gonna do gating totally
legal for one night only get your
tailgating in before times up people I'd
love to know how these mercenaries knew
how to aim the flaming ice cream truck
to hit cars that just happened to be
driving by on perjures everywhere
especially in low-income areas all data
supported early violent behavior and
then a downturn what data did you have
some trial purges before we got the
first experiment and what would it
matter if they started earlier later
anyway kind of bull line is this marks
so these because overseas after I listen
sure is awesome Dimitri's got a
lieutenant and in his drug gang who just
happens to be in the military to give us
much-needed exposition about mercenaries
if I didn't forgive you when I couldn't
see anything on the screen outside at
night I sure as hell I'm not forgiving
you for the fact that these people are
working in complete darkness indoors
movie stubbornly refuses to be
illuminating in any way whatsoever
you're sending soldiers into the island
disguised as gangs as citizens scientist
who works for a clearly evil government
is shocked shocked that her resident
g-man would Goose the purge results to
make purging more viable also once you
find out something like this wouldn't
want to keep it to yourself do you think
an evil government's gonna leave you
alive once you tell them that you know
their dirty secret a secret by the way
that is no more or less evil than coming
up with a purge in the first place what
have I done
you'll be accidentally includes Marisa
Tomei his first words after signing on
for this film as part of the script
Dimitri grieves for a dead guy but I
don't know why I should care I mean this
is the kid he gave basketball pointers
to 45 minutes ago but he ranks barely
above the guy who dressed up as Santa
for Bella and Twilight on mic give up
come eater
while these people run down the street
and try to find safety here's a guy with
a flamethrower burning a random guy
falling down some steps it has nothing
to do with the characters we're
following but all right you happy you
could see at least one asshole get burnt
the fuck up seriously I just want to
know how these people got fired up to
purge tonight but found the patience to
hide out in places where very few people
would dare to come close
I'll make that footage disappear like
why did you even need to kill her this
way in the first place
you could have witnessed her death
anywhere and it wouldn't have required
this camera also what an unceremonious
end to Marissa Tomei is character if you
deserve way more than this I mean this
might be the stand-in for Marissa Tomei
in the footage
that's how unceremonious this is I say
no one character says something and
another follows it up with for now
cliche a meet Rayna screw through smoke
grenades at the mercenaries applauding
the area so they can't see but
apparently Dimitri's gang are experts at
finding and killing people in a smoke
cloud as if they're from the planet
Marlboro one thing you may not realize
about smoke and fog is that it has no
effect on dimming the color red
apparently isn't blood landing on the
camera lens the same as breaking the
fourth wall it's no one else distracted
by the fact that there shouldn't even be
a camera lens there to land on no one
just me fine I'm still sending that ball
because I made a youtube channel when
dammit I'm gonna use it but how does he
even know that niya is there last he
knew they were still hanging at the
church right these drones picked this
time to blow away a whole bunch of
people and then are never heard from
again what's the point of sending
mercenaries into a situation if you can
just drone the battle large groups of
people like this and at least bring them
back into the story somehow where the
could those things go during the other
three movies also this is just too much
of a risk for the government in this day
and age of capturing video any number of
assholes could be shooting footage of
this right now and exposing the nffa
with a simple upload to youtube and
maybe Vimeo if they're really serious
about the craft
they're gonna move from floor to fucking
and as many as they can okay why are the
Park Hill towers such a coveted kill
zone for the mercenaries why is a mass
murder here so important for the results
of the purge doesn't killing people in
this manner suggest more than average
citizens getting pissed off and
unleashing their anger we know Dimitri
is strong for sure after all we saw him
running on a treadmill earlier but he's
got like actual Jason Bourne type skills
that I didn't realize a life of drug
dealing could account for this mercenary
he's joking is spending his evening by
killing low-income minorities for
population control while wearing a mask
representing blackface this asshole may
have achieved maximum racism guess we
aren't worried about any kind of
subtlety here are we he's well-trained
military dudes decide to wait in the
hallway like sitting ducks
letting dimitri mow them down like
they've never trained for this situation
before guess I won't be needing this
anymore also is this someone I'm
supposed to know from the other movies
see a purge legacy is a series so
predictable at this point that there
will be a movie called
purge legacy
I know Comic Relief has to Comic Relief
and all but when you're hiding from some
sort of future government Nazi death
squad maybe don't do it so loudly I'm a
shoot low there legs I say you jump in
and finish the Mafia this works these
guys just busted down a door with two
tables and a mattress in front of it and
yet they don't think there's anybody in
here did these mercs get their training
from an online course while Dimitra
prepares the c-4 to blow up these
stupid-ass mercenary guys I'm now
wondering what the are these guys even
shooting at right now they're firing
toward the open doorway but not the
walls and if we've heard one thing in
this movie it's that this apartment
complex is a piece of so those walls
should be easy to fire through objects
in mirror are closer than they actually
are also are they shooting at the mirror
that is in plain sight I can't hit can
they after one of the mercs says light
them up which is a direct order to fire
now another 10 seconds goes by while
they wait for Skeletor to show up and
stabbed them to death
Skeletor whom the movie forgot for 30
minutes finally arrives to the apartment
complex to kill Naya and Isaiah
after apparently wandering the streets
looking for them in other places that
were not the apartment good thing too
because he serves as an ironic ex
machina the heroes badly needed to
survive the day despite the fact that
Dimitri and one-man wrecking crew is
lying in wait in front of them and they
could easily just shoot the Rockets and
kill him now the entire mercenary crew
focuses their attention on Skeletor
because you know he has a knife Dimitri
tackles Naya and is able to drag a
mattress over them to protect them from
the fire we what not to mention I don't
care how strong you are you're not
grabbing a mattress by one hand and
giving yourself cover at the speed of
that explosion all that blood isn't
yours
you've got shot in the stomach but we
know your abs are practically
bulletproof so none of it hardly matters
no one character says something in
another character follows it up we fight
and because of their sacrifice
determination and first-hand testimony
the purge was abolished and never
happened again
yeah well happy endings this is how the
first purge ends giving us no real
insight into how from this one
experiment the purge was sanctioned
throughout the country just ends which
I'm very happy with but I thought the
point of this movie was to show us why
the government thought this was a
success aside from all the deaths this
dude shows back up again but he has
nothing interesting to say other than
that we'll be studying the results what
was this movie
girlfriend sparked on boyfriend's kids
far beyond appearances a fat lady far
thinner person what do you do when you
get angry I'm on drugs
Oh bother you ain't talking but you
telling me everything what we got here
is a little game of show-and-tell you
don't to show me nothing but you tell me
everything and listen you wanted to meet
you stop calling us cuz we keep moving
WM Dave right chair right chair
look at me sure look at me sure I'm the
captain now when I open the trunk you
pop up rack this mother there's only fat
bullets in you beats a damn spatula no
where did you get that lovely spatula
well you got protests all over the place
now Marissa Tomei loves phony Corky
Goldman and six months ago
when Doug introduced me to you guys I
thought I just added two more guys to my
wolf pack